en este vídeo voy a querer hablarles
sobre el interés compuesto y aunque en
otros vídeos ya habíamos hablado acerca
del interés compuesto esta vez que
hacerles un pequeño resumen o un pequeño
recordatorio de todos lo que hemos visto
el interés compuesto interés compuesto
vamos a hablar acerca de cómo se compone
el interés y bueno vamos a verlo
esencialmente con un ejemplo para ver
todo lo que hemos aprendido imagínense
que vamos corriendo a un banco y este
banco nos ofrece el 10% de interés
compuesto bueno realmente no creo que me
ofrezca el 10% de interés compuesto
porque lo que hacen ellos es ofrecerte
un cierto interés continuo después
haremos un vídeo acerca de lo que es el
interés continuo pero supongamos que en
esta ocasión me ofrecen un 10% de
interés compuesto qué quiere decir esto
bueno a lo que se refiere es que si el
día de hoy yo depósito en el banco 100
pesos entonces después de un año y ojos
después de un año porque estamos
hablando de un interés compuesto
anualmente yo voy a obtener el 10% más
de 2 100 pesos es decir yo voy a obtener
mil 100 pesos de mi inversión original
más
el 10% de 100 pesos que son 10 pesos es
decir al final del año yo voy a obtener
110 pesos muy bien esto es lo que le va
a pasar a mis 100 pesos que invertí
originalmente después de un año al 10%
de interés anual
ahora qué va a pasar en el segundo año
en el segundo año y aquí es lo
interesante del interés compuesto porque
esta vez no vamos a obtener el 10% del
interés de 100 pesos más bien vamos a
obtener el 10% de la cantidad final que
obtuvimos después de un año de inversión
es decir vamos a obtener el 10% de la
cantidad de 110 pesos y es importante
mencionar aunque sé que suena obvio que
estoy invirtiendo otra vez todo mi
dinero es decir estoy invirtiendo los
110 pesos que yo obtuve en el primer año
de ganancia íntegros por lo tanto ahora
sí en mi segundo año yo voy a obtener
los 110 pesos en mi primer año más el
10% de esos 110 pesos que son 11 pesos y
en total en el segundo año
yo ya tendría 121
esto quiere decir que el interés
compuesto se refiere a sacar el interés
del interés que ya obtuvimos ahora vamos
a ver lo siguiente supongamos que yo
tengo un cierto depósito y qué va a
pasar con este depósito después de n
años entonces yo tengo un cierto
depósito y este depósito que hay que
hacerle para obtener la cantidad final
que vamos a obtener después de n años
bueno hay que multiplicarlo por 1.1
bueno antes de eso mejor vamos a
intentar hacerlo con más calma para no
confundirlos fíjense bien por qué por
1.1 si se dan cuenta este 110 salió de
multiplicar 100 por 1.1 si multiplicamos
a 100 por 1.1 obtenemos 110 y en el
segundo año que pasó pues yo multiplique
100 por 1.1 que da 110 otra vez por 1.1
es decir 100 por 1.1 que me da 110 por
otra vez 1.1 por 1.1 y seguramente se
están preguntando de dónde salió este
1.1 bueno el 1.1 sale porque nosotros
teníamos originalmente el 100% y a éste
le agregamos el 10
es decir el 1.1 sale del 100% original
que nosotros depositamos más el 10% de
interés compuesto anual y por eso
estamos multiplicando cada vez por 1.1
al principio una vez por 1.1 la segunda
vez dos veces por 1.1 y creo que ya
están viendo el patrón después de tres
años vamos a tener los 100 pesos
originales que multiplica a 1.1 elevado
al cubo es decir 1.1 por 1.1 por 1.1
tres veces y si nosotros quisiéramos
saber qué va a pasar con esos 100 pesos
después de n años funciona muy lógico en
lugar de poner 3 poner n y no es que sea
muy abstracto alain recuerden que la n
es una cierta cantidad de años en la
cual quisiéramos saber cuánto vamos a
obtener ahora bien todo este tiempo
hemos estado hablando acerca del 10 por
ciento de interés compuesto anual qué
pasa si le cambiamos al 7% de interés
compuesto anual bueno después de un año
tendríamos esos 100 pesos multiplicados
por y esta vez en lugar de por 1.1 vamos
a multiplicarlo por 1.07 recuerden que
el punto 07 sale del 7% de interés
y después de tres años pues nosotros
tendríamos 100 x 1.07 elevado al cubo
muy bien y tomen nota pues estamos
multiplicando por 1.07 porque estamos
hablando del 7% y tengan cuidado no es
1.7 elevado al cubo porque eso sería
hablar del 70% ahora yo les tengo una
pregunta cuánto tiempo vamos a necesitar
para que nuestro dinero se duplique o
vamos a decirlo de otra manera cuánto
nos tomara que nuestro dinero sea el
doble para esto vamos a suponer que
nuestro capital inicial son 100 pesos
entonces ahora lo que yo necesito saber
la cantidad de años en los cuales mi
dinero se va a duplicar tengo 100 x 1.1
estoy suponiendo que estamos hablando
del 10 por ciento de interés anual
elevado a la equis lo que queremos es la
cantidad del tiempo y eso nos tiene que
dar igual a 200 es decir el doble de
nuestro capital inicial y yo lo que
quiero sacar a la
por lo tanto lo primero que voy a hacer
es pasar el 100 dividiendo y yo tengo
que 1.1 elevado a la equis es igual a 2
y ahora como despejamos a x bueno en
nuestras clases de interés compuesto que
habíamos visto anteriormente para sacar
a x teníamos que utilizar el logaritmo
es decir hablar del logaritmo en base
1.1 de 2 y esa es nuestra respuesta si
lo que queremos es despejar a un
exponente lo que tenemos que hacer es
utilizar la función logaritmo logaritmo
en base a la base del exponente y bueno
dese cuenta que para obtener este
resultado es necesario una calculadora
si nosotros lo que quisiéramos es
hacerlo a mano tendríamos muchos
problemas porque tendríamos que ir
aumentando el exponente en exponente
hasta obtener un número cercano al 200
pero si nosotros tenemos una tasa de
interés compuesto del 9.5 por ciento
anual se haría cada vez más difícil en
nuestro siguiente vídeo vamos a terminar
de resolver este problema y vamos a
hablar acerca de la regla del 72 aquí
nos faltaba la palabra más importante
que era dinero duplicar nuestro dinero y
ahora si en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
ver cómo hacerlo con la
el 72 que es más fácil